and we're doing heat on this [ __ ] nice
nice keep it that way sex sells number
one rule from the real rejects hey guys
how you doing i'm ryan right and i'm
katie do pop today we're gonna check out
a trailer for a movie called manglehorn
is how you say it I don't know yeah
whatever manglehorn uh it stars yeah
Petrino and holly hunter Holly Hunter
Howard [ __ ] you sit up do you know my
favorite flavors chicken C a nice string
that's confusing I like vanilla vanilla
that's really confusing it's a strange
flavor friary
dear Claire loving you is the only thing
I haven't done night
your new awareness very simple address
that Claire Hughes delivered who's Clara
she was very special woman in my life is
really great
I'm only man Claire I got real pain in
my heart maybe this other woman she'll
return
then maybe you'll remember how to love
someone
dear Claire the world's changed so much
I'm around for so many years dear Claire
I just want you to look at me one more
time
trust me to be ruined I'm gonna angry
man but I'm quite so angry at you
will be great you could do to be a
father is that we're being a daddy it's
okay yeah okay it's okay it's okay
I'm going to clean out my garden I'm
gonna dig up the roots gonna start
something fresh
so what you see
you got nice eyes for the record I kind
of like your hands see you search army
there's something there's something
charming but there's something strange
about him and this like maybe Clara does
not exist you know like something maybe
it's wrong Clara perception maybe yeah
maybe he is Clara he dresses up like her
at times whoa that would be gone with
the rest of the movie that's what that
would be cochino is one of those actors
that if I hear he's in it I'm going to
take a look at it master does it mean
I'm always gonna go out of my way to
check out like if it happens to be on
netflix i'll check it out because i do
love Al Pacino I was just watching
Donnie Brasco yesterday and that is one
of my favorite performances of him have
you seen that no missing out yeah burn
in hell that escalated I am so sorry I
was just gonna say that you should make
a movie list for me to watch now without
that some people I've been being like we
want out Pacino to return but I feel
like Al Pacino has been doing great
performances just not in big films over
the last few years if the bigger film
sees intend to not be good it makes
sense why some people still have this
perception like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
or something I hope this one gets more
attention because I really do think it's
cool to see him in a more sincere more
heartfelt rolling I like that complete
complexity that you're talking about
like who is she really like what does
she actually exist he has the right
level of someone who seemed so sincere
but is a little off putting a little
detached yeah maybe the reality of the
circumstances yeah so you get this
interesting it makes for a more
interesting character rather than us
actually knowing who this woman is maybe
maybe in the movie we find out like five
minutes in but from the trailer i like
how i didn't reveal that because it does
add an actual dimension to him that's
like maybe this guy's a little bit crazy
a little bit but you know he's a likable
crazy dude and that makes
much more interesting character to watch
than just some regular old Joe I love
the guy be cast for his son to I know
I've seen him in a bunch of stuff but I
thought he was a perfect son for Pacino
Pacino hmm techny said Pacino Pacino
Pacino Pacino but but she knows but she
know when uh Katie goes to an Italian
restaurant she orders Italian
celebrities last names Wow could that be
a restaurant that can be reversed friend
I would like it the best she Holly
Hunter what Holly Hunter holly hunter no
thank you she is she's always so nuanced
and like special to me she is the kind
of like a tough elegant woman I fell
again yes she is fantastic for so long
you know she's been doing that since
like the early 90s when no one was doing
you know tough and elegant at the same
time she was she's got it the first
movie I saw her was copycat hmm cut have
you seen that I have it what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you look I can't there are
literally millions of movies yeah and
you have to watch at least what's fifty
percent of a million five hundred
thousand thousand but do you send
millions so you don't know what the half
for me and this director he did a movie
with Nicholas cos Nicolas Cage it's not
like what she know where he's secretly
been doing great movies he randomly does
a great movie like every five years
nicolas cage right and then he does a
lot of there's a lot of shitty movies in
between but he did a movie with david
gordon green i think it was called joe
and that was another performance of
nicolas cage in the last like ten years
that people were like this is actually a
really good performance or nicolas cage
that makes me feel more confident in
having him as a directory as if he was
able to like help Nicolas Cage look cool
again for a couple hours I'm hoping that
that can really branch out with Al
Pacino because you know like by me doing
a trailer reaction by us doing a trailer
reaction than reviewing it it gives the
film more attention hopefully so yeah
hopefully inspires you guys to go
waters yeah you'll probably have to
search for it but go find it yes
fandango com rating time I will watch
manglehorn if my friends want to watch
it too I will probably watch manglehorn
and some independent theatre by myself
on a rainy day depression anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to today's episode
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects katie has
a channel to the KT du Bois channel yeah
she yet you should check it out it's
actually it's actually entertaining I'm
boring right on actually entertaining
it's weird and you can false on facebook
instagram and twitter where if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement meaning less work for me and
no benefit for you for things such as he
sees too many props in the last video i
meant on the remotely the light bulb i
want to get sponsorship from light bulb
companies light bulbs are great they
illuminate things and blah blah blah
let's off to the kinky [ __ ] you can also
attach it to your nipple like this and
then when you want to light it up you go
and then it makes you look like a bright
nipples and you get a [ __ ] adrenaline
rush from out shopping your tit katie
has a channel i didn't mention that last
time oh yeah Leo stop